- Le gouvernement martèle qu'il
mais exit le méga-tunnel entre
Québec et Lévis à six voies
et deux étages;
la CAQ revoit ses plans.
ministre des Transport du Québec
- Un tunnel bitube qui aur
une gestion dynamique des voies.
GENEVIÈVE GUILBAULT, ministre
responsablmomomomomomomomomomomr
et qui va néanmoins continuer
d'atteine e les objectifs
qu'on s'était fixés.
- Le gouvernement propose
voies chaque pour réduire les
coûts d2525 %, à 6,5 milliards
de dollars. La nouvelle mouture
aura
aux autobus, mais seulement
heheheures de pointe.
Le ministre Bonnardel a donné
nouvelles études à présenter.
- Je travaille là-dessus, là.
- La CAQ soutient que 126
voitures empruntent le pont
Pierre-Laporte chaque jour.
D'ici 2036, on prévoit
qu'il y aura presque
143 000 déplacements
entre les deux rives; et
le gouvernement souhaite aussi
des communautés plus à l'est.
- On est qui pourerere
à ces familles : Parce que ça,
c'est la mode
la densification, que tu dois
vivre dans uououour?
BRUNO MARCHAND, maire de Québec
- Le gouvernement seul peut
ou non sans l'appui du maire
dec.c.c.c. Aujourd'hui,
je ne peux pas faire l'apologie
de ce projet-là.
convaincu : pour l'instant,
les impacts sur l'environnement
du tunnel l'inquiètent.
- L'étalement urbain,
on ne peut pas être rassuré.
maire de Lévis
- Est-ce que l'étalement urbain,
ça signifie que les communautés
ne peuvent plus se développer?
C'est un non-sens!
est sans équivoque.
- Moi, je trouve que c'est
un excellent projet. Je suis
convaincu que ce projet-là va
aller chercher l'acceptabi
- Les citoyens sont partagés.
- C'est une chchchchose
d'avoir un tunnel.
- Je ne pense pas que c'est
qu'on devrait entretenir
ce qéjéjéjéjéjà.
- Je suis correct avec ça, oui,
oui. Moi, c'est quelque chose
qui me plaît.
- C'est un projet
t t t t t nécessaire.
- Alors que le fédéral répète
que ses priorités demeurent
les projets de transport
en commun, François Legault
est catégorique : il réclamequ'e
de la facture.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Évidemment, moi, je m'attends
et je ne veux pas envisager
d'autres scénarios que de voir
le fédéral présent pour 40 %.
- Le gouvernement Legault avait
promis une première pelletée
de terre pour son projet
de troisième lien avant
la fin d'un premier mandat.
Il lui reste un peu moins
de six mois.
Ici Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc,
Radio-Canada, Québe